[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur les
plateformes du figaro vous êtes au coeur
du figaro vous êtes en direct et on
attend vos points de vue notamment sur
les auditions de jean françois
delfraissy et de didier rahout au sénat
ou plus exactement là la confrontation
avec les deux lignes on va les
confronter en tout cas ses points de vue
avec ceux de philippe meyer bonsoir
philippe bonsoir animateur et créateur
du nouvel esprit public
un podcast absolument à écouter à
retrouver sur internet
le nouvel esprit public.fr ça y est
c'est déjà dans le château et dans la
description sur youtube sur youtube
très facile à écouter à retrouver à
télécharger
face à vous avec si vous réservez
bonsoir alexis le figaro fait sa une
aujourd'hui sur la confrontation entre
lieux et la chine et demain sur une
autre bataille celle autour du
déploiement de la 5g d'ailleurs c'est la
question du jour sur le site du figaro
il y a également à retrouver une
interview exclusive de jean pierre
pernaut ça tombe bien on va y revenir
enfin deux en fin d'émission sur la fin
de jean pierre pernaut au trésor annoncé
pour la fin de l'année
on parlera aussi des fractures
françaises 2020 la dernière enquête en
date de l'institut ipsos steria et ce
chiffre très commentée 55% des français
favorables au rétablissement de la peine
de mort est ce que c'est votre cas ou
bien est ce que vous êtes
effrayé par ce chiffre vous pouvez
répondre à la question elle est posée
sur twitter mais d'abord on va revenir
au sénat avec une série donc d'audition
dans le cadre de la commission d'
enquête sur le vide et la prise en
charge par la gestion de lait par l'état
de cette crise commission denquête donc
cette fois-ci sénatoriales avec
notamment d'abord ce matin l'audition du
président du conseil scientifique jean
françois delfraissy on retiendra
notamment cette sortie et cette pique je
comprends très bien les questionnements
qui se pose de la part à la fois de nos
concitoyens et de vous-même en disant
mais dans le fond on entend tout et son
contraire de la part d'un certain nombre
deux personnalités scientifiques alors
d'abord séparons bien ce qu'est le
comité scientifique qui prend la parole
vous êtes probablement pas remarqué mais
au moment où nous sortons des avis c'est
à dire qu'on s'appuie sur ce que nous
venons de construire ou la pensée c'est
s'est écrite
c'est avec une vraie réflexion autour de
cela et puis ce barnum un peu médiatique
qui existe depuis maintenant omis avril
qui s'étaient calmées un peu pendant
l'été qui reprend là depuis trois
semaines et où monsieur duchmol madame x
etc se croient tout savoir et c est
prendre la parole sur les médias je le
regrette daniel b la musique vous dira
qu'il ya et vous peuvent approfondir sa
en disant qu'on a une absence de
régulation autour de ça et nous avons
essayé de d'essayer autant que faire se
peut de cadrer les choses mais c'est
deux choses différentes et je le
regrette mais après on touche à des
choses complexes 1 qui sont que iana ya
un devoir d'expression naturel qui
existe en france et c'est difficile de
comment réguler ce ses prises de paroles
qui peuvent exister alors un barnum
médiatique dénoncé par jean françois
delfraissy également des madame x ou des
monsieurs duchmol alors derrière
monsieur duchmol personne n'est nommé
mais certains ont cru reconnaître la
barbe et les cheveux au carré la
coiffure au carré d'un homme qui était
masqué cet après midi toujours dans
l'hémicycle du sénat didier raoul tu
vois si lui l'institution ou la
désorganisation qui le mettent en cause
mais en maladies infectieuses
ici on a détruit l'organisation des
mâles direction elle n'existe plus et
donc si vous retrouvez avec un port
marseillais en train de vous dire ce
qu'ils pensent c'est parce qu'il ya une
destruction physique de l'organisation
des maladies infectieuses qui était à
l'hôpital claude bernard là les forces
de maladies infectieuses l'institut de
veille sanitaire a été mis à saint
maurice alors que c'était une vraie
bonne idée moi j'avais écrit à l'époque
de le mettre à côté de pasteur ou de
maître - des antennes de pasteur à côté
voyez le les hôpitaux de maldic
spécialisé en maladies infectieuses ont
été dispersés
dans toute la ville et donc vous n'avez
pas de sens vous n'avez pas de pardonnez
moi je vignes vous n'avez pas de patron
et si de maladies infectieuses voulait
pas alors que vous l'aviez il ya 30 ans
vous l'avez pas vous avez des patrons
dans les autres domaines vous avez des
gens qui sont des leaders dans les
autres domaines dans ce domaine là vous
n'avez pas de leader
vous n'avez plus de leaders
microbiologie celui qui était le
meilleur a été tellement dégoûté séance
publique est parti en suisse
d'accord donc vous avez il ya un
problème ici avec les maladies
infectieuses
un véritable problème d'évolution l'asie
placer qui fait des choses absolument
remarquable s'est éloigné et petit à
petit avec le temps de la pratique les
maladies infectieuses à l'hôpital
pasteur donc quand j'étais jeune on
faisait tous les diagnostics l'institut
pasteur l'épidémiologie partout voilà
c'est du personnel petit à petit cette
partie là a disparu pour être remplacé
par par des parrains une recherche
fondamentale beaucoup en neurosciences
sont parmi les meilleurs du monde
donc je ne veux pas une critique de la
qualité de ce qui se passe
il ya une désorganisation qui a une
désorganisation de ce pays et qui se
voit ici pour ce sujet alors il n'y a
pas de grands patrons en matière de
microbiologie en matière d'infectiologie
on précise que ça fait partie des
justement des qualifications de jean
françois delfraissy
alexis les sénateurs ont déclaré à
plusieurs reprises qu'ils étaient très
malades très mal à l'aise quant à la
division du corps médical
est-ce que c'est pas ça le problème les
sénateurs ne crois pas que les que les
gens soient pas tous du même avis fasse
quelque chose de très compliqué c'est un
peu normal même si ça serait trop simple
si tout le monde était du même avis
personne ne sait exactement c'est un
truc nouveau est en quête des avis
différents qui s'exprime
mais là où le professeur delfraissy même
paraître un peu à côté du sujet ou même
au niveau long terme c'est quand il fait
semblant enfin quand il nous dit oui il
ya notre avis qui est toujours le même
puis à d'autres qui viennent nous
parasite est d'ailleurs bon on les
tolère mais en fait il faudrait réguler
en gros ne pas leur permettre de parler
comme ça serait plus très clair est que
le nôtre mais le sujet personne ne
reproche à d'autres fins certains disent
que le cas où tu dis n'importe quoi que
tu as retenu je dis n'importe quoi
d'accord mais fonctionnellement personne
ne reproche à des médecins de dire le
contraire
comité scientifique ce qui me paraît
reproche à ces fonds des cds que le
comité scientifique lui même a dit tout
et son contraire
c'est ça le vrai sujet fait semblant de
pas le combat mais il a tout dit et son
compte alors les masques c'était
caricatural communauté scientifique il a
dit qu'il servait à rien qu'il fallait
les maîtres queux l'intérieur puis qu'il
fallait mettre les intérieurs
l'extérieur puis la nuit puis le jour
enfin ils ont changé d'avis au moins
cette fois sur les masques bon mais ya
pas que ça il y avait il y avait
l'immunité de groupe
monsieur le professeur delfraissy a dit
un jour qui avait débuté deux groupes
l'un d'eux makan avait plus piquant fait
on savait pas qu est-ce qu on peut la
rechute
il a dit que je crois quasiment le même
jour une fois en italie qu'on pouvait
rechuté et pendant ce temps en france il
est non on peut pas rechuter donc dès
que le professeur delfraissy
un homme très politique à présider tous
les comités de la terre qu'on peut
présider présider et qui a une technique
de dire blanc noir gris parce qu'il faut
qu'à la fin il est toujours dit quelque
chose qui était vrai c'est un politique
mais il faut pas nous expliquer qu'il
n'a jamais changé d'avis donc voila moi
je trouve que on peut pas être d'accord
avec le brevet sa route
on peut ne pas être d'accord avec tel ou
tel ou tel mais l'organe qui était censé
exprimer une position derrière le cadre
des politiques et je vais laisser la
parole à philippe d'ailleurs les cas les
politiques ont eu trop tendance à se
retrancher au début je pense qu ils ont
heureusement maintenant ils sont en
train de reprendre la main c'était ce
comité scientifique
ce comité scientifique lui-même a
pataugé depuis le début dans cette
histoire c'est ça le fond du problème
chypriote a opposé à ce que je dis enfin
peut-être pas maso obligé derrière n'a
reposé est ce que vient de dire alexis
j'ai juste ajouté que surout lui même
n'a pas fait preuve d'une grande
constance dans ses déclarations sur les
pelles et visuel 10 qui dit la mérite
d'être d'être entendu sur la
désorganisation de la recherche dans ce
domaine particulier est en effet sur le
la dispersion
souvent d'ailleurs pour des raisons qui
n'ont rien à voir avec les le bien de la
science mais quand à voir avec une sorte
d'idéologie de la décentralisation ou de
l'éclatement ou
je pense que ça c'est un véritable
problème mais pour le reste je suis
d'accord avec alex et professeur de sur
la crise inouïe nous mène en bateau en
nous disant en effet une chose et puis
et puis ensuite en nous disant son
contraire alors il pose une question qui
est la question de la régulation mais la
régulation de qui la régulation des
scientifiques vous parler de la
régulation de la parole il a parlé de la
régulation de la parole mais on régule
la parole depuis la parole des
scientifiques alors on pourrait imaginer
qu'elles soient régulés en effet par la
structure dont parlait après lui le
professeur raoul c'est à dire par une
espèce de hiérarchie claire est admise
par la majorité des parts la majorité
des médecins qui sont concernés par ce
sujet mais on voit bien que derrière ça
il pose aussi la question de la
régulation de la parole sur les plateaux
de radio et de télévision
comment est-ce qu'on régule la parole
sur les plateaux de radio et télévision
décide on publie la liste des médecins
autorisés à parler alors évidemment on
peut pas nier non plus que dans beaucoup
de chaînes d'information directe
c'est-à-dire en réalité dans tout
peut-être une exception qui france info
qui me semble c'est un peu mieux
conduite que les autres mais dans les
chaînes d'informations en direct quand
on n'arrivait pas à avoir un professeur
avec des plumes dans le derrière enfin
l'eau sur le chapeau sur le jeu le
chapeau pardon je le regarde alors à ce
moment là il fallait un médecin il
fallait un ou des médecins parce qu' il
fallait une parole qui ait une apparence
scientifique alors on faisait quoi on
appeler son médecin
ça donnait à peu près cet impressionnant
c'est à dire que moi j'ai un généraliste
vous allez voir il va vous dire tout ce
qui va venir
le tipi vient il est à la télévision il
est très content il faut qu'il dise
quelque chose qui ait l'air un peu
original ou différent de ce qu'on dit
les autres et à ce moment là on entend
des trucs qui sont absolument
extravagants jusqu'à cette dame médecin
qui a été abondamment interrogé qui a
qui tourne sur les réseaux sociaux et
qui a tourné aussi sur les chaînes de
télévision en direct dame qui expliquait
que ce sont des satanistes pédophiles
qui ont inventé l'idée de
du virus et de et qui veulent nous faire
mettre le masque pour nous apprendre à
marcher ou pas qu'est ce que vous cette
information vous arrive
si vous êtes un journaliste sérieux
qu'est ce que vous faites vous asseyez
dessus vous la mettez à la poubelle si
vous êtes un journaliste qui fait dans
le sensationnalisme et qui de toute
façon pense que un buzz va chasser
l'autre
eh bien vous donner la parole
abondamment à cette dame et c'est ce qui
a été fait là il ya un problème qui est
de l'ordre de la responsabilité des
journalistes parce que il se trouve que
le journalisme ne peut fonctionner
qu'avec des gens responsables pas avec
des gens friqués ou encadrer à qui on
dit voilà qui vous pouvait interviewer
voilà qui vous ne pouvez pas interviewer
alors je vous précise que cette dame
entre les caennais peuvent rêver je ne
les connais pas de quelle n'a pas été
sur ses plateaux et dans le marais
comment sortir
non mais c'est vrai que c'est difficile
aussi facile et c'est pour tout le monde
personne ne sait exactement donc c'est
vrai qu'ils ont cherché l'invs ont
changé autant alors c'est vrai qu'ils
ont parfois tendance à chercher ce qu'on
appelle le bon client
c'est vrai que si raul tu avais pas eu
sait manier cette ce physique de droïdes
peut-être qu'il aurait sans doute moins
d'impact parce que c'est vrai que dès
qu'une chaîne de d'un faut aller le
chercher il fait une audience
considérable parce qu'il le personnage
est marrant et or plus il disait des
choses parfois contradictoires mais
malgré tout on avec un fil directeur je
prétends pas du tout se vend si vidéo
chloroquine ça marche marche pas je n'en
sais rien mais un fil directeur
on retrouve à peu près à chacune de ses
interventions qui était de rassurer
c'est en gros ils disent et moi qui est
la vraie seule comédie après greffe au
on ne sait pas eu ça va pas durer quand
ça se réchauffe ça se calme puis
finalement c'est pas si grave
je dis pas que c'est vrai je dis juste
que un type qui a un physique qui en
plus des choses qu'on a spontanément
vite croire on a plutôt envie de croire
que c'est pas si grave est que ça va
s'arranger
plutôt que ces terribles qu'on va tous
mourir donc il ya un biais de perception
qui fait qu' il faisait d'audience les
gens sont allés le chercher mais ça ne
résout pas la question de savoir s'il a
raison ou tort bas ce qui me frappe
je vous la jeunesse moi je ne sais pas
mais c'est que quand même maintenant ça
fait un moment que cette histoire dure
ça fait presque un an et on en est
encore à discuter de savoir si oui ou
non les
les et romy si ça marche ça marche pas
c'est quand même surréaliste maintenant
depuis le crash c'est pas moi je ne suis
pas scientifique mais on devrait le
savoir ce qu'ils pensaient qu'ils
étaient pour au début ils sont toujours
pour et ceux qui étaient contrôlés au
début ils sont toujours content et assez
peu de gens qui ont changé d'avis et
quand même chose assez ce mystérieux
parce que d'en attendant ce match là
pardon pour ajouté philippe on a eu deux
visions quand même aujourd'hui encore au
sénat
la vision effectivement défendu par le
professeur delfraissy et des années où
il a où il a oeuvré pour sûr sur le sida
avec favorable à ces grandes études
qu'on appelle randomisée et également la
vision défendue par raoul tu cet après
midi qui est elle de faire des la
médecine d'observation et donc de faire
du de faire du terrain et expérimental
oui mais il ya une contradiction dans ce
que dit raul d'abord malheureusement sur
les drogues cycle rockin on sait on sait
parce que toutes les études aboutissent
au même résultat qui est de dire ça ne
marche pas ça ne marche ni au début ni
au milieu ni à la fin de du nominé par
mais savent que l'anti petit con mais
avec la dont j'oublie tout le monde sait
que ça marche finalement c'est le truc
complémentaires oui oui mais c'est moi
ce que vous en train d'écrire du cac les
antibiotiques en général ont finalement
un rôle dans le traitement
je me souviens dans mon enfance il y
avait des processions pour la pluie il y
en a deux ou trois que l'on marché et ça
finit toujours en marche et une grosse
énigme et puis ça fait super marché en
ce moment ça ferait du bien d'ailleurs
peut-être devrait-on organisé mais raul
tient plusieurs discours celui du
médecin qui dit moi je soigne comme je
soigne pas quelquefois je bouscule un
peu les règles et je note un médicament
qui n'est pas au nom de la logique du
soin c'est vrai que dans un contexte cas
d'excès rappeler c'est à dire celui dans
lequel on a l'impression que personne ne
sait rien on a tendance à se dire après
tout si la thérapeutique qu'il propose
est seulement inutile c'est pas grave
l'essentiel c'est évidemment qu'elles ne
soient mal n'aggrave pas la situation et
si elle est utile tant mieux on le verra
mais au lieu de s'en tenir à son
discours de médecins de soignants il
monte immédiatement dans les hauteurs de
des généralités et il explique à partir
de là quelle est la politique qu'il
faudrait faire et que ça va s'arrêter et
que c'est pas grave et que c'est pas
parce que je le cite il ya un chinois
qui meurent qu'il faut arrêter
l'économie du pays et aussi il explique
qu'il a sauvé marseille j'ai
malheureusement quand on regarde les
chiffres d'aujourd'hui je crois pas que
marseille soit sauf et il s'en faut
j'aurais aimé qu'ils ne savent à
marseille puisque je suis à moitié
marseillais est à moitié mais rooney
donc l'aveyron ça va merci mais encore
qu'il ya une année parce qu'ils ont
apprises et un ehpad ans est vrai que le
château qui en a pris un mauvais coup à
ses limites et là bon donc voilà c'est
ça qui fait que lui aussi au lieu de
contribuer à rassurer comme le pensent
et alexis contribue aussi à affoler
parce que il ya trop de contrats des
relais ou bien à hystériser un peu près
pareil mais c'est quand même vu ça à
hystériser à cliver la transformer un
débat en bagarre pour les pour les
contre les compter pour sauver une
guerre de religion que à affoler puisque
quand même ce qu'il dit est plutôt
rassurant donc le jour d'ici pas si
c'est plus cela n'affole pas ce que dira
ou pas qui affole c'est que personne
sont d'accord pour estimer que ce qui
peut nous affoler en tout cas nous
inquiète et nous déstabiliser les uns
les autres c'est de voir que il n'en
sait pas plus que nous alors que c'est
son métier passe puisqu'il nous dit
qu'il a sauvé marseille et que marseille
est loin d'être sauvés puisque il nous
dit que hydroxy chloroquine et que les
études que se sont faites par des gens
dans des pays où ils sont jamais entendu
parler du professeur out etc alors en
même temps d'un côté on sait que c'est
un grand bonhomme au point de vue de la
recherche que il a que dix trucs
d'accord mais si c'est pour rentrer dans
cette espèce de panier de crabes
on a toujours su que la médecine
s'étaient sayah puissiez si les gens ont
envie de lire quelque chose sur le sujet
il ya un livre de léon daudet qui
étaient mes voyages leur domaine qui
s'appelle les morts qui colle et qui
décrit les milieux de la médecine savent
pas vers qui met du tout
angèle 10 e bracelet que je vous trouve
malgré tout un peu injuste il n'a pas
dit qu'il avait sauvée pour l'éternité
massa il a dit que quand il y avait des
malades lui savait les soigner et pas
les autres
ce qui n'est peut-être pas vrai je
m'empresse de le dire mais il n'a pas
dit qui aurait plus jamais être malade
sa c'est pas lui qui surveille le
confinement pendant l'été et les gens
qui vont faire la fête à marseille
pendant l'été même réseau il n'y est
pour rien non mais c'est lui qui a dit
que l'épidémie était c'est vrai et bon
coup je sens que les gens n'avaient pas
besoin de lui dans la france entière
pour ce faire croire que c'était fini
parce que c'était l'été grenat leur mère
ça aide
alors philippe raoux et n'a jamais dit
qu'il avait sauvé mars à fait ce que
nous dit cette interview monsieur meyer
je viens d'écouter vos questions il n'a
pas de cela raul tête en conflit avec
les responsables de la santé nous dit
l'onu c'est dommage que son expérience
soit bafouée pour cette raison la
prouver vous les critiques de didier
rahout à l'encontre du conseil
scientifique dirigée par jean françois
delfraissy
c'est la question que l'on vous pose sur
sur twitter et vous répondez oui à 63%
peut-être une dernière chose il y as par
rapport à ce que vous disiez il ya une
phrase je trouve assez frappante dans
l'audition de raul tu ce matin cet après
midi c'est le fait qu'être sur le
terrain ça nous a fait changer la façon
de voir les choses
est-ce que c'est pas ça aussi qui
explique le fait qu' il ait pu évoluer
dans son discours peut-être écoutez moi
je suis pas désireux d'enfoncer le
professeur raoul t et tant mieux si les
raisons pour lesquelles il a changé
d'opinion sont de bonnes raisons je n'en
reste pas moins sur cette idée qu'il
s'est trop souvent contredits pour ne
pas contribuer à notre désorientation
juste un mot sur delfraissy plus qu'on
en parle il est quand même l'auteur de
cette formule absolument qui doit rester
pour l'éternité dans les mémoires qui et
quand il était président du comité
national d'éthique mois le bien le mal
je ne sais pas ce que c'est ce qui fait
que sylviane agacinscki avait dit que
qu'il était discrédité jusqu'à la fin de
ces voix là c'est donc il ne sait pas
aujourd'hui sur le sur le quotidien on
peut pas lui reprocher mais sur
l'éthique savais pas
pestis qu'effectivement dont il était
donc l'un des guerres ethniques au
moment d'être la discussion des lois
bioéthiques
oui il ya une phrase dans le dans la
folle de chaillot de giraudoux il ya une
phrase du syndic de la publicité qui dit
à entre la vérité et le mensonge ne me
demandez pas de me départir de mon
impartialité allait repasser un autre un
autre débat
tout aussi grave c'est
vous pose une question sur twitter est
ce que vous êtes effrayés par les
derniers chiffres des sondages
concernant les français et la peine de
mort donc ces chiffres sont issus d'une
enquête annuelle de l'institut ipsos
steria pour le compte de plusieurs
groupes nos confrères du monde de la
fondation jean jaurès ou encore du
cevipof de sciences po 55% donc des
français qui se disent favorables au
rétablissement de la peine de mort sur
twitter et l'ancien ministre socialiste
michèle delaunay et effrayé horreur dit
elle 55% des français sont en faveur de
la peine de mort soit une augmentation
de 11 % précise d'ailleurs que c'est le
plus haut niveau d'approbation depuis la
création de cette enquête parce que
c'est chaque année que ces mesures aient
et ça jamais atteint ce niveau philippe
meyer à ce que vous partagez le
sentiment de michèle delaunay oui ça
fait peur bien sûr ça fait peur alors
qu'est-ce que ça traduit une appareil de
l'ensauvagement de la société elle ce
qu'est ce qu'elle se ce qu'elle devient
féroce ou est-ce que ça traduit un
désarroi devant le sentiment que aucune
politique pénale aucune aucune politique
policière n'aboutit ou peut-être même
qui n'existe pas de politique pénale aux
politiques policières je pencherais
plutôt pour la deuxième hypothèse je
pense que c'est un désarroi je n'en
trouve pas moins que cette augmentation
fait peur oui et kehl
alors je pourrai pas elle fait peur
parce que c'est une façon de dire on
veut rien savoir on voit rien savoir et
puis
après tout qu on remette la guillotine
en fonction mais je voudrais revenir un
peu sur le sujet c'est de réfléchir sur
l'histoire de ça on a supprimé la peine
de mort
c'est le robert badinter qui a été
l'artisan la peine de mort était la clé
de voûte du système pénitentiaire il
fallait donc et du système pénal il
fallait donc en enchaîner avec une
réforme une refonte complète du système
pénal badinter l'a pas fait on peut
comprendre pourquoi son affaire c'était
la peine de mort quand on a accompagné à
la guillotine des gens dont un qui
n'était pas qu'ils n'étaient que
complice et canton bon c'est devenu son
affaire et et au fond sans doute at il
eu le sentiment qu'il avait accompli sa
mission complètement quand il a réussi à
faire rejeter cette abolition françois
mitterrand se fichait complètement de la
politique pénale et de la politique
judiciaire
il a été un garde des sceaux pitoyable
il a été un garde des sceaux j'allais
dire méchant et quand on publiera les
archives du de la période où il était
garde des sceaux et encadrement on a
appliqué la peine de mort un grand
nombre de gens qui soutenaient le fln on
verra si je suis bien informé
si je me trompe tant mieux tant pis je
ne sais pas et on verra qu'il n'a jamais
été celui qui a fait pencher la balance
du côté des grâces il n'y a donc pas eu
de réforme de la politique pénale
il y en a jamais eu il n'y en a jamais
eu
pas plus le successeur de robert
badinter que le successeur immédiat je
veux dire que madame taubira madame
taubira parlant vers et en prose
admirablement elle réussit d'ailleurs
sur ce plan à à séduire beaucoup de
monde mais la politique pénale de madame
taubira se limite à peu près rien les
successeurs c'est pareil et donc
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
non seulement il n'y a pas de politique
pénale mais où en même temps il n'y a
pas de doctrine de maintien de l'ordre
si je puis dire
et il n'y a pas les moyens que ce
maintien de l'ordre soit assuré
il ya aujourd'hui peut-être faudrait-il
s'en soucier presqu'à l'égal de ce
sondage est aujourd'hui un conseiller
d'arrondissement de paris monsieur lycia
qui publie sur les réseaux sociaux
les vidéos de bande qui dans paris
échanges désir de me retrouver là je
sais tu sais ça donne une idée de la
décomposition de l'ordre méric et dans
l'incapacité de répondre au désordre
public
bien sûr c'est une des causes de ce de
ce changement d'opinion qui est un
changement
vertigineux on a tous dit répété et ça a
été vrai pendant des années que
l'abolition de la peine de mort était
une réforme qui était minoritaire dans
l'opinion et que petit à petit elle
était devenue majoritaire et que c'est
d'ailleurs la preuve que le politique
quand il sait prendre de l'avancé dans
le sens de l'humanité sur sur le sur les
électeurs fini par les convaincre et que
le finalement le bien le mal triomphe
c'est ce qu'on a expliqué pendant une
heure et puis là tout à coup ça
s'inverse donc pour qu'une si pour
quelque chose ça lasse ça va ce n'est
peut-être pas durablement fin n'empêche
qu'on n'a jamais vu ça un sondage où la
peine de mort et ça veut dire qu'il
s'est passé quelque chose ça sort pas
d'un chapeau et je crois que finir
touche du doigt la réalité c'est à dire
que c'est un cri de colère ce sondage
c'est on n'en peut plus d'un sentiment
d'impunité qui va depuis le très grand
criminel et combien de deux crimes
atroces de multirécidivistes ont défrayé
la chronique de gens dont on se dit
miserait du passé leur vie en prison et
d'ailleurs quand on avait supprimé peine
de mort on avait dit ça on avait dit oui
à pas la peine de mort mais y aura une
perpétuité réelle et puis on s'est rendu
compte finalement de fil en aiguille qui
a pas de capturer elle qui a perpétué du
tout et que les gens quand ils font déjà
la moitié de leur peine c'est bien
maximum ses locaux montrent d'ailleurs
dans un jeu qui est donc par bruno
depuis l'option ville depuis les très
grands criminels jusqu à ce qu on
appelle de façon pudique et par
antiphrase parfois les incivilités les
tirs de mortiers les machins où les gens
se disent mais finalement les criminels
sont sont jamais vraiment punis mais les
français les citoyens les gens les
honnêtes gens disent il faut qu'un jour
les criminels soient punis si on les
punit pas parce que l'on veux pas les
mettre en prison alors
nous comptons leur la tête donc ce qu'il
ya derrière ça c'est le sait la patte de
notre système judiciaire qui je crois
n'est pas dû au hasard qui est due aussi
au fond une idéologie qui est qui
courait pendant une grande partie de la
magistrature et de l'intelligence et
interac et celles de la gauche
judiciaire qui est qu au fond que la
sanction pénale c'est mal c'est pas bien
parce que au fond le coupable n'est
jamais vraiment tout à fait coupable
c'est la société qui à travers lui est
coupable et que donc on croit s'en
débarrasser en le mettant en prison mais
non il faut leur éduqué il faut il faut
le réinsérer tous à toute chose tu
résultat est formidable et tout ça mais
il ya un moment où les gens disent mais
quand est-ce qu'on est punis
et si on les punit pas de façon ferme
clair en mettant de la prison elle
disait alors ce moment là qu'on prend la
tête la peine de mort est un crime on
nous dit j'aime c'est en revanche si
nous avions une justice responsable il y
aurait moins de criminalité ou
délinquance c'est ce que vous dites
notamment philippe mais le même vous dit
il ya quand même des moyens notamment
pour mettre des pour mettre des contres
des contraventions et mettre des
gendarmes sur les autoroutes oui ça vous
voulez que je vous raconte une anecdote
que j'ai pas eu le temps de se dire mais
qui sont de 4 aveyronnais parti de paris
pendant le confinement et qui se sont
retrouvés à la sortie de l'autoroute à
saint flour sortie à l'issue de laquelle
il ya une gendarmerie donc toutes les
chances de vous faire prendre ils ont
été arrêtés par les gendarmes qui l'ont
dit où habitez vous donnez moi vos
papiers habite à paris ce que vous
faites là bas on veut avoir votre grand
mère elle va pas bien bon aller où votre
cas mr aller dans tel village japon très
bien elle a le téléphone votre grand
mère
oui alors on téléphone à la grand mère
qui est pas du tout dans mon village là
qui va d'ailleurs pas mal donc les
gendarmes l'ont dit bah écoute c'est
très simple c'est 4 soit 135 euros 1 par
tête de pipe
si vous faites demi-tour et demain vous
allez au commissariat de votre
arrondissement pour prouver que vous
être rentré alors tout ça a été
parfaitement dans le ton de la
régulation de la circulation au moment
de la môme en dehors de la pandémie mais
au moment du confinement
mais non je dis je je n'entre pas dans
l'idée que les juges sont trop ceci ou
sont pas assez cela je rentre je
voudrais souligner qu'il n'ya pas de
politique pénale et il ne peut pas y
avoir de plaisir qu'on a on n'a pas du
tout imaginé
et un système de sanction qu'ils soient
des sanctions réaliste dont certaines
peuvent parfaitement être fait en dehors
de la prison parce qu'on sait que la
prison n'a pas beaucoup de effet positif
sur les gens qui sont à part de mettre
la société à l'abri sq s'est déjà des
images
pardon je la jouerai juste interrompre
un instant c'est à dire qu on a encore
eu un atroce fait divers ya pas si
longtemps
qu'est ce que c'était c'est une histoire
de viol avec le gars avait fait un peu
plus de la moitié de sa peine ce qui est
beaucoup s'éprouve considéré comme très
dangereux
bon il fait un peu plus de la moitié ont
libéré heroes violent e-reçu je veux
bien qu'on dise que de mettre quelqu'un
en prison jusqu'au bout de sa peine
ça ne le change pas parce qu'un homme ça
ne change pas et que peut-être salle
empire mais non parce que si ce gala
avait fait sa peine jusqu'au bout ils
n'auraient pas violer et tuer cette
malheureuse jeune femme donc c'est pas
rien non plus de mettre la société à
l'abri c'est quand même à ça que ça sert
la prison commençons par eric et des
vrais perpétuité pour les irrécupérables
danger public ni je pense qu'il faut se
référer à lévi strauss est opposée à la
pensée sauvage la pensée domestique et
la pensée sauvage a tendance à partir
d'un fait épouvantable à en tirer une
généralité la pensée domestique et
essaye de rassembler l'ensemble des
fêtes pour voir s'il n'y a pas moyen
d'en tirer quelque chose qui soit un peu
plus calme si je puis dire et encore une
fois ce qui nous manque c'est aussi bien
une doctrine et une politique de
maintien de l'ordre
parce que là aussi il est clair que y
aurait pas de tirs de mortiers échangées
dans paris si c'est bien le cas mais
j'ai vu les images mais je me méfie des
images comme de la peste puisque créée
on avait vu à grenoble des rameurs qui
s'était découvert en terre les mortiers
ça fait des années que ça dure
les pompiers on a fait mille reportage
on raconte des pompiers des policiers
appelés à intervenir dans des cités de
médecins qui depuis les immeubles se
font tirer dessus avec ses mortiers qui
sont des feux d'artifice un il faut pas
non plus qu'il va des mortiers le
militaire mais enfin ça peut faire très
mal ça peut d'y figurer ça peut mettre
le feu à un véhicule
ça peut marcher les mains vives quartier
donc c'est pas du tout nouveau
l'histoire des mortiers
et pas du tout nouvel les pompiers ont
vite ça au quotidien depuis des années
des années ont fait rien oui et bien en
face de ce comportement là est un
comportement délictueux parent
comportements incivils en face de ce
comportement délictueux quels sont les
moyens que la police a pour intervenir
c'est eux je pense que le dernier
ministre de l'intérieur qui a eu une
politique c'est pierre joxe
je pense que si aujourd'hui on regarde
le film de bertrand tavernier l 627 on a
une vue y est je pense aux films à plus
de 20 ans je pense qu'on a une vue dont
il doit quand même trente ans tu as fait
et je me souviens j'enseignais à
sciences po les poids que sur paris son
histoire et c'est un peu moins longtemps
28d et j'ai fait venir le directeur la
police judiciaire un aveyronnais et la
première question qui leur a posé à mes
étudiants qui étaient là c'est combien
d'entre vous ont vu le film de monsieur
taverny l 627 un peu pâle et deux tiers
combien d'entre vous croire que c'est la
réalité de la police directement police
judiciaire pas beaucoup qui ont osé
lever la main en me disant eh bien ceux
qui croient que c'était là c'est la
réalité de la police se trompe c'est
pire et c'est toujours pis pour ceux qui
n'ont pas vu l 627 on voit des policiers
sans moyens dans des variateurs aurait
dit avec des paperasses à n'en plus
finir et tout ce que vous voudrez et
dans des commissariats crasseux comme le
sont aujourd'hui la grande majorité des
cas biesheim et alexis provenir des
affaires de mortier ce qui me frappe
c'est que ça existe depuis des années
des années notamment en banlieue et cas
pourquoi est-ce qu'on en parle parce que
vous avez raison c'est un maire adjoint
ou un nom un élu conseiller
d'arrondissement de paris et que ça se
passe à paris ouais et tout mais on dira
mais c'est incroyable en plein paris les
bornes se tirent dessus à coup de
mortier mais ça se passe tous les jours
et depuis des années en banlieue la
bomba c'est un peu boss les territoires
perdus
c'est dire qu'on a renoncé les policiers
ont renoncé à y aller et les pompiers
tous les ambulances qui parfois n'ont
pas le choix parce qu'il faut intervenir
mais il fallait beaucoup de quartiers où
les pompiers quand il va intervenir ce
fonds précédé de policiers devant de
publicitaires y compris parfois les
camions poubelles ne peut vendre
certaines cités qu'avec comme la
diligence a entouré de la cavalerie
devant et derrière
donc parce que sinon ils se font tirer
dessus c'est un sujet ça c'est pas une
question de politique pénale c'est une
question de respect de l'ordre aient
raison à quoi je voudrais ajouter sur la
question de l'évolution de la
délinquance que l'absence de politique
en matière de drogue aussi énormément
joué que la manière dont cette
délinquance la quête une délinquance
extrêmement importante parce qu'elle
suit délinquance qui est extrêmement
juteuse
cette délinquance est étendue à la
totalité du territoire
j'en ai vu des exemples dans des
endroits qui m'ont fait tomber de ma
chaise ou au vent puis on vend pas de
l'air à bocanda cultivés sur son sur son
balcon dans un port au vent de la
cocaïne dans des endroits qui sont par
exemple dans l'aveyron dans le nord de
l'aveyron dans le sud du cantal dans des
endroits qui sont agricoles qui parlait
trop et qui ont dû paraître idyllique à
tous ceux qui le sont d'ailleurs à bien
des égards à tous ceux qui sont venus y
passer leurs vacances cet été
etes-vous alarmés par le sondage
d'opinion révélant que la majorité des
français approuvent la peine de mort
c'est la question que vous posez sur
twitter alors vous êtes une petite
majorité répond non 58% les
commissariats témoigne philippe de
banlieue sont maintenant des places
fortes avec des grillages même anti
cocktail
il y a énormément d'effectivement de
témoignages il ya également un débat sur
la peine de mort on n'y revient pas à
l'intérieur du chat ou les deux les deux
arguments et les arguments qu'on repart
qu'on voit les uns qui disent que c'est
pas dissuasif et les autres qui disent
que ça l'est en tous les cas pour celui
dont subi l'intérêt de la société de
soigner et de réinsérer les personnes
qui sont toxiques pour elle-même estime
pour sa part pierre et arès nous dit je
trouve inquiétant qu'à notre époque nous
ayons encore cette fameuse peine de mort
sur la table on verra et bien dans les
semaines qui viennent
et l'an prochain lors de la prochaine
livraison de ce sondage si le taux à 2
français à les entendre à l'opinion m
que l'abolition de la peine de mort est
inscrite dans loué durant lequel jeunes
aussi dans dans le la charte européenne
des droits de l'homme oui qu'elle engage
la france même au niveau des traités
internationaux pas pour tirer que comme
boris johnson
c'est le sujet du dernier podcast du
nouvel esprit public qui vous pouvez
retrouver sur internet sur boris johnson
c'est une part contre une info exclusive
révélée par le figaro et confirmée par
l'intéressé lui-même
jean pierre pernaut donc quitte à la fin
de l'année la présentation du trésor
sans quitter tf1 à regret de voir
pernaut partir et vous peut être à
chercher un terroir hammer j'ai été
bouleversée j'ai failli ne pas venir
tellement je veux noyait dans mes larmes
mais je me suis souvenu d'une chose
quand même et peut-être alexis s'en
souvient quoi qu'il soit quand même
beaucoup plus jeune que moi se nommait
neuf ans il y avait à l'époque où il n'y
avait qu'une télévision publique
quand ya eu trois chaînes il y avait une
émission qui avait la particularité très
étrange d'être diffusée simultanément
sur les trois chaînes tous les jours à
la même heure 19h20 19h40
ça s'appelait les actualités régionales
et ça donnait de la france s'enfonce une
image à côté de laquelle les magazines
de jean pierre pernaut donne
l'impression d'avoir été concoctée par
la cellule anarchiste de tarmac donc
fonda depuis
l'époque de la rtf on a fait des
avancées je dirais après pour le reste
jean pierre pernaut s'en va au bout de
temps en temps il va faire autre chose
honnêtement bon jeu le journal de 13
heures c'est pas dans nos métiers c'est
pas un moment on regarde beaucoup la
télévision donc je peux pas de parents d
un grand champ j'ai vu par contre sur
lci
ses émissions sur la france où on voit
défiler comme ça ça donne ça c'est
franchement d'un cul cul moi je suis pas
du tout d'accord avec ce que dit
philippe moi je trouve que c'est vrai
qu'il était de bon ton pendant des
années de pincer le nez en parlant du
journal de pernaut qui tiennent énorme
succès énorme machine en audience en
publicité a tout de formidables dont il
faisait bon c'est un truc de ploucs
c'est ça que les gens penseraient à
paris tout ça et puis quand même avec le
recul quand on regarde tous ces sujets
qu'il a fait pendant des années et des
années sur l'environnement le patrimoine
culturel le patrimoine tout court la vie
c'est exactement ce qu'on redécouvre
aujourd'hui ce que les genres découverts
pendant le confinement et et et et dont
on se dit ah il faut faire maintenant
des gens dans une solution faire du
journalisme positif mais le père noël
fait ça depuis des années comme monsieur
jourdain faisait de la prose sans savoir
c'était pas c'était il n'ya pas une
théorie il succéda mourousi qu'il est le
plus grand chez de tous les branchés
techno tout ça il le fait ce qu'il est
mais il a trouvé un public il a su
parler à des gens il a su parler de ce
qui est leur vie est ce qu'il est sans
racines dans un temps quelque chose de
sensible et de deux culturel et moi je
trouve que c'est une très belle réussite
journalistique que c'est pas qu'une
réussite d'audience arrivé à intéresser
les gens avec ces sujets là avec comment
on fait du camembert dans la ferme de
marie harel à voir comment on fait du
pastel dans le lauragais et bien ça ça
m'intéresse
oui il manque quand même beaucoup de
choses dans ces sujets là ce que j'ai vu
encore une fois je regardais pas le 13h
ou alors vraiment très très très très
épisodiquement mais dans les sujets que
j'ai vu sur lci où j'en ai vu un peu
plus
par exemple la suppression des lignes de
chemin de fer et les conséquences que
cela peut avoir
j'ai pas le souvenir qu'il en ait
beaucoup parler pas plus que des
problèmes de drogue dont je viens de
passer dans des actes positifs dont il
avait raison oui mais c'est du passé
madame à la sécurité avec un jour de sa
peut pas être enfin je prends dont le
l'alpha et l'oméga du journalisme mais
alors que année un peu c'est comme de
temps en temps pas plus mal et
d'ailleurs les gens sont aussi heureux
de ça aucune date en tentant sans donner
alors matière d'insécurité a été décrié
parce que justement il en avait parlé de
façon un peu plus décomplexée que dans
le reste de la profession on l'avait
reproché d'avoir monté papy voise et
tout ça à la grande époque avec
notamment avec notre envie voir je vous
donne juste un témoignage c'est que en
matière de sens de l'info pernod était
très réactif et ils essaient pour aux
équipes qui étaient sur le terrain une
parfaite liberté ils faisaient une
grande confiance et donc dès qu'ils
avaient de l'info et en particulier de
l'info internationale dans le 13 heures
ils demandaient toujours avoir des
reportages donc voila c'était teva
contribution aux témoignages merci
beaucoup de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve demain
pierre durieux qui nous dit jean pierre
pernaut et apaisant c'est ce qui fait
son succès c'est comme effectivement ce
que vous disiez sur des syrahs route
en tout cas le figaro va se transformer
d'un gant tranquillisait donc vous
retrouver demain c'est pas très apaisant
demain le fil le figaro revient sur la
bataille autour de la 5g et la question
qui est posée sur le site faut-il
déployer la 5g
en france on se retrouve demain même
heure même endroit avec guillaume
roquette a trahi son filet
[Musique]